this is just like a personal blog for
ariana and
picarey personal news why i'm now
leaving msnbc
you know why she's leaving because her
fake news
finally it's it's refreshing to see
someone actually
leave because i mean that's that's
basically what you did you know when
they were like
they wouldn't let me leave well yeah
like what did you do though
i mean i still didn't work all year i
did work but they didn't like what i was
producing
yeah so i worked for a company as a
joint venture between abc news and
univision
and they did not like the content i was
doing because
they wanted to do social justice because
it was honest
no no it's not it's not even that i went
to work i went to fukushima i know it
was cool
yeah so i went to japan and we did this
story about um
you know the radioactive you know
disaster the nuclear disaster
it was it was a clever idea i was like
the idea i had for a good documentary
series was to take a look
at video games and movies that have
concepts
and then produce documentaries around
the concept so you have like a
non-fiction version that explores the
ideas
so when fallout 4 was coming out i was
like why don't we go and
go to you know fukushima we'll call it
fallout from fukushima
and then when everyone's really excited
about this video game we'll have like a
hey here's the real world you can learn
some you know facts and it worked out
really well yeah it was a good it was a
good series
so the interesting thing about it is not
political they didn't like it
they wanted they wanted woke politics
and i didn't want to do it i want those
clicks baby
well i don't know it wasn't clicks i was
getting clicks i was getting more views
than like basically anybody at the
company
and they even told me that the president
of the company said you get more traffic
than anyone else here and i was like
then why won't you listen
they were obsessed with embracing far
left intersectionality and feminism
and i could only i could only speculate
as to why based on
what i was told by their consultants so
the consultants may be the end-all
be-all but it was basically them
they believed that in the next several
years this country
will be entirely intersectional seems
like they weren't entirely wrong though
the company didn't
couldn't succeed in actually generating
any kind of buzz but they believed
within the next you know five to ten
years or so
this would be it the entire country
would be woke and therefore you must be
woke
now to get in early to win wait hold on
what happened to them
didn't they go broke oh yeah they went
super broke
all that money just gone yep well take a
look at this story let's let's actually
read
so i'm not familiar with who ariana
pakeri is
but she writes quote just quit that's
the advice alec gave a year and a half
ago
when i expressed concerns about my job
you just quit
it's that simple stay at msnbc at least
until the midterms jeffrey said a couple
years back
he advised to watch and see what happens
hang in there you're needed
elizabeth recommended last winter i was
in your shoes when i was younger but i
stuck it out
a year and a half ago simply quitting my
job without knowing my next step
sounded pretty radical so i stuck it out
a bit longer
until we were in the middle of a
pandemic to make a truly radical move
july 24th was my last day at msnbc
i don't know what i'm going to do next
exactly but i simply couldn't stay there
anymore
my colleagues are very smart people with
good intentions the problem is the job
itself
it forces skilled journalists to make
bad decisions on a daily basis you may
not watch
msnbc but just know that this problem
still affects you too
all the commercial networks function the
same and no doubt that content seeps
into your social media feed one way or
the other
it's possible that i'm more sensitive to
the editorial process due to my
background in public radio
where no decision i ever witnessed was
predicated on how a topic or a guest
would rate
the longer i was at msnbc the more i saw
such choices
it's practically baked into the
editorial process and those decisions
affect news content every day
likewise it's taboo to discuss how the
rating scheme distorts content
or it's simply taken for granted because
everyone in the commercial broadcast
news industry is doing the exact
same thing but behind closed doors
industry leaders will admit the damage
that's being done
quote you're gonna love it you guys
ready for the nuclear bomb yeah
we are a cancer and there is no cure
a successful and insightful tv veteran
said to me
but if you could find a cure it would
change the world
it's easy it's the the easiest cure in
the world
you just stop stop watching
you stop watching everyone stops
watching them everyone realizes that
they're fake
no one's going to go their ratings it's
you know look msnbc
and and cnn are as fake as they can get
yeah but people are addicted to this
stuff they believe it they trust it
and they grew up being told fox news is
fake news
fox news is biased for sure
but their daytime news stuff is actually
really good and i've heard journalism
professors say this stuff
but the left can't accept it they've
been wrapped up into this resistance
insane mindset and this is what you get
you get people who exploit this and they
grow and become powerful
now to be fair if you look at my content
it is absolutely hyper focused a lot of
stuff we talk about
is you know very political it has its
bias and everything
but there's a big difference between you
know from my content
a dude who reads the news and talks
about his opinion and tries to make sure
you know i'm telling you what i think is
reasonable and honest the best of my
abilities as kind of a
you know independent left-leaning kind
of person and then you have
for this show a small group of people
just opining on
cultural issues and politics and talking
about the election coming up
when you compare those things the big
difference to like say msnbc is
an editorial boss who says no i know you
care about that story adam we're not
going to run with it
because it's not going to do well for
the show but i want to talk about space
but we're going to talk about space so
that we actually have spacex ready you
know yeah so we're going to talk about
like spacex and stuff
and there have been segments we've done
i can't remember which segment we did
didn't do all that well
and it was something we wanted to talk
about but that's the thing
when you're an individual and you're
like here's stuff i care about and i
want to talk about this
and people like listening to what you
say about these certain topics you'll do
well
but then if you look at youtube guess
what youtube where all of this political
commentary exists
is not unified if you watch you know
stephen crowder
you're going to get a conservative
opinion you watch tim pool you're going
to get a more moderate opinion
you watch kyle kalinski will get a
progressive opinion and it's all under
the same
youtube imagine if msnbc was like that
you'd turn it on at any given point or
you go to their website and you have a
bunch of different political opinions
that's what happens when youtube and
facebook
or whatever i'm not a big fan of these
big tech companies but when they allow
individuals to create content you end up
with independent
editorial decisions and and i i'll i'll
talk to people who say they watch me
they watch crowder and jimmy dore jimmy
dore i think is a socialist
is it he's pretty far left yeah he is
he's socialized yeah because i don't
want to
you know tell him what his views are i
think jimmy's great he's
anti-establishment
he's he's you know pretty far left but
there are people who will watch
all of us that's good for you
if you only watch msnbc you're probably
going insane
and that's why this woman quits let's
read a bit more she says as it is this
cancer stokes
national division even in the middle of
a civil rights crisis
the model blocks diversity of thought
and content because the networks have
incentive to amplify fringe voices and
events
at the expense of others all because it
pumps up the ratings
this cancer risks human lives even in
the middle of a pandemic
the primary focus quickly became what
donald trump was doing poorly
to address the crisis rather than the
science itself
as new details have become available
about antibodies a vaccine
or how covet actually spreads producers
still want to focus on the politics
important facts or studies get buried
this cancer risks our democracy even in
the middle of a presidential election
any discussion about the election
usually focus on donald trump not joe
biden
a repeat offense from 2016. trump
smothers out
all other coverage also important is to
ensure citizens can vote by mail this
year
but i've watched that topic get ignored
or killed numerous times
wow context and factual data
are often considered too cumbersome for
the audience there may be some truth to
that
our education system really should
improve critical thinking skills of
americans
i'm sorry ariana i don't think they help
i think they hinder to be honest
but another hard truth is that it is the
job of journalists to teach and inform
which means they might need to figure
out a better way to do that they could
contemplate more creative
methods for captivating an audience just
about anything would improve the current
process
which can be pretty rudimentary think
basing today's content on whatever rated
well yesterday
or look to see what's trending online
today well she did make a good point
though about that education she said it
really
should right improve not that it that
it doesn't that's what she's saying it
should the the schooling
so you know you just said you don't
agree with her but she's literally
saying that
school should improve critical thinking
skills that's what we need
more people using critical thinking to
handle things i guess i should say to
clarify
i don't think schools will work i'm not
i'm not convinced that
without some kind of radical absolute
deconstruction of the entire system and
reforming in a totally radical and
different way
i am 100 opposed to institutionalized
learning facilities
which separate kids from their parents
so they don't learn from their parents
puts them under the care of people who
typically don't care about them and then
sends them off to colleges where you got
a bunch of radical lunatics
who don't actually work in their field i
agree the system is
messed up the school system needs i mean
it goes back to unions really the
teachers unions are protecting bad
teachers
and it's a bad system it's it's so
beyond that though
it's it's it's partly rooted in the fact
that people use school as daycare
yeah yeah we were talking about earlier
so i'll ask you something about college
what would you rather let me ask you
guys what you think
if someone was supposed to learn how to
you know run a media business or be a
producer in a media company
would they be better served spending all
of their time in school and going to
college for it
or literally just sitting across the
room from us right now
and every time we do a show i'm just
looking over she didn't you didn't go to
school for this
i did not no i uh i i came in and i sat
down next to tim and i learned
everything i know from tim
and it's been great super hands-on and
everything i need to know i learned as i
needed to know
the point is obvious you have a lot of
people going to journalism school and
they're learning from people who aren't
actually in the field you look at these
journalism professors on twitter and
what are they they're far left
they're all far left and i'm like they
don't even know what they're talking
about half the time
like i mean facts like sure you can give
your opinion on you know the morality of
objective versus subjective blah blah
blah
ethics and all that but do you even know
the fact
you didn't do any research so you have
these professors
they've actually called me in to give
guest lectures on like methodology and
technology and
new reporting techniques so why would
you spend money
to to literally go to a room to learn
from someone who isn't
working in the field it makes no sense
but anyway that's a whole other
conversation let's go back to uh
ranting about the media she says
occasionally the producers will choose
to do a topic or story
without regard for how they think it
will rate but that is the exception not
the rule
due to the simple structure of the
industry the desire to charge
more money for commercials as well as
the ratings bonuses that top tier
decision makers earn
they always relapse into their old
profitable programming habits
i understand that the journalistic
process is largely subjective and any
group of individuals may justify a
different set of priorities on any given
day
therefore it's particularly notable to
me for one that nearly every rundown at
the network
basically is the same hour after hour
and two
they use the subjective nature of the
news to justify economically beneficial
decisions
i've even heard producers deny their
role as journalists
a very capable senior producer once said
our viewers don't really consider us the
news
they come to us for comfort msnbc
whoa you know what i to say though can't
stand him
it's true of everything though i'm sure
it's true for a lot of people come to
watch us
yeah but all i can really say is
we look msnbc has a boss
and that boss tells the underlings who
tell their underlings
these stories don't fly at this network
we talk about what we think is important
we often
pull up the biggest stories of the day
and then we literally just give our
feelings about it
and often adam and i will disagree about
it imagine if in this show i was like
adam you got to stop doing that it's
better for the ratings if you just say
what
what should be said instead of what you
actually think oh i want i'm resisting
the urge to give him two middle fingers
but i'm not gonna do it nope because
we'll get demonetized will they will we
no that's a joke no i don't want it i
don't want people clipping that
all right right right well no so but
look there's a fair point in that we
won't swear
because we it's you lose money yeah well
i mean to be fair
i am probably overly critical i got i
get several emails from people asking us
not to specifically so their kids can
listen in and stuff like that
yeah about it so i'll be i'll be fair in
that regard but i do think it plays a
major role in why i won't swear
why why should i lose you lose like 70
percent of revenue when you say one
swear word
yeah some ridiculous amount so it
absolutely does play a role in everyone
but ultimately though what i think i
want to talk about i just
i just talk about it and and the same
for you know what we do versus what they
do
i don't think there's a perfect solution
though i think any company that grows
enough will fall
victim to this yeah i think even if i
were to make a massive company
were i to maintain editorial control i'd
be like no i don't like that story for
this reason
why are we you know wasting time on
these certain things and that's why when
it comes to say scanner
which is doing production i tell them
you pick you do what you want to do
and i think that's the best i can say
for us how i'm trying to do things
differently to stop
this we've got scanner if you're not
familiar and they're off producing stuff
and the most i can do is like why would
you guys do this and that huh
interesting whatever but they have full
editorial control i don't
and that's how it's supposed to be
newsrooms are supposed to be editorially
independent for this reason
they're not she says personally i don't
think the people need to change
i think the job itself needs to change
there's a better way to do this
i'm not so cynical to think that we are
absolutely doomed though we're on that
path well i disagree i think the media
industry
is doomed if that's what she means i
know we can find a cure
if we can figure out how to send a man
to the moon if alex trebek can defy the
odds with stage four pancreatic cancer
and if harry reid can actually overcome
pancreatic cancer he's now cancer-free
then we can fix this not everything that
is that is faced can be changed but
nothing that
nothing can be changed until it's faced
she says i know james baldwin wasn't
thinking about msnbc
when he wrote that line in 1962 but
those words spoke loudly to me in the
summer of 2020.
unfortunately many of the same ailments
are still at stake today
now maybe we can't really change the
inherently broken structure of broadcast
news
but i know for certain that it won't
change unless we actually face it in
public
and at least try to change it now i got
to be real it sounds like she's actually
like a lefty democrat liberal like she
it doesn't seem to be a fan of trump she
seems to be into social justice but she
knows the destruction
the damage of this whirlpool of fake
news you know who she reminds me of a
little bit
who is matt tybee yeah a little bit
these liberals are waking up man
yeah and and they have voices i
appreciate that yeah
she says those pandemic and the surreal
alienating lockdown
through this pandemic i've witnessed
many people question their lives and
what they're doing with their time on
this planet
i reckon i'm one of those people looking
for greater meaning and truth
as much as i love my life in new york in
new york city and really don't want to
leave
i feel fortunate to be able to return to
virginia in the near term
to reconnect with family friends and a
community of independent journalists
i'm both nervous and excited about this
change thanks to covid19
i'm learning to live with uncertainty
and so very soon
i'm going to be seeking you out any one
of you who will also
who also may sense that the news is
fundamentally flawed and is frustrated
by it
this effort will start informally but i
hope to crystallize a plan for for when
better
safer days are upon us on that front
feel free to reach out anytime
if you'd like to discuss any of this
whether in agreement or not
more than ever i'm craving full and
civil discourse until next time
thank you for reading i wish you all
well ariana that's so great you know
it's interesting
civil discourse that's what she's
wishing for yep exactly
bill maher recently ran a segment where
they were wishing for
civil discourse they were they were
complaining about the far left cancel
culture
and now we're starting to see more more
and more so i know bill maher has called
us out but we're starting to see more
and more people are challenging the far
left
the anti-discourse narrative and they're
challenging how the media is fueling
into this so bravo to her
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you